they say the only constant has changed
but that's not true if your doctor whose
companion so as I mentioned in a
slightly offhanded fashion in my review
of the witch's familiar Jenna Coleman
has been confirmed as leaving Doctor Who
which means Clara will be gone I was
ready for her to be gone at the end of
series 8 because she had two perfectly
good exits one in death in heaven the
other one the last Christmas they didn't
use either of them I don't know why
she's still around but that is all in
the past let's not dwell on the past
let's look to the future what do I want
out of a new companion well actually I'd
rather talk about what I don't want out
of a new companion because here's where
things have gotten really on my nerves
with Doctor Who which is we are in such
a rut when it comes to companions they
fit a pretty rigid template now given
that I'm actually deviating from how I
chose to define a companion when I did
my ranking of companions I should
clarify when I did that video I was
talking about any character who has been
in more than one story and has traveled
in the TARDIS qualified as I've been
companion I'm not talking about that in
this case this time I'm talking about
characters where the actor who played
them is named in the title sequence now
I said they've been following a Richard
template there's basically three
characteristics that nearly every
convenience so far has had and I just
want the next campaign to not have all
three of these and those aspects are
female young from modern-day earth very
tired of this
they've only deviated from this once
rhythm that was Donna and the only way
that she deviated was she was a little
bit older now that actually did make a
difference and that was part of why
she's actually my favorite companion
because that actually did change up the
dynamic a bit I suppose the other
exception could be worry but the thing
is he's never there under his own agency
he's only there as a tag on for Amy I
mean that said it I did like him being
there I like the dynamic of the three of
them the doctor Amy and Rory but again
Amy was always the main companion I
don't think anyone's arguing otherwise
so this is the template I want broken no
more young attractive women from the
modern day earth timeline I'm just done
with it I mean if you saw my review of
Magician's apprentice then you know how
that I am because I had kind of hoped
that Bors would try out to be the next
companion we know he's not because he's
Dalek she'll thing whatever that is but
that's how hard I'm rejecting this
template at this point I would rather
have seen a guy clearly over 30 from the
distant past
so obviously scrapping all three of
these trends would be my ideal but
really I didn't ex companion is I need
them to not take all three of these
boxes just one of them has to be
different if I was gonna prioritize I'd
say the modern earth thing is the one
I'm most desperately want to see go out
the window that was part of what annoyed
me about Clara in the first place was
that we had gotten what to me were much
more interesting versions of the
character with Oswin and with the
governess and I would much rather either
of those versions have been the
companion for the doctor rather than the
one from modern-day earth just like all
the other ones even though the same enos
of the young attractive woman is
bothering me a little bit I'm not as
hung up on that one because that has
always been the template for Doctor Who
going back into the classic era anything
that is not an attractive female is the
exception rather than the rule but you
know within that framework classic
Doctor Who went so far out of its way to
shake that up and have variety even
within that narrow field because yes you
had ones who fit all three categories I
talked about Jo grant Sarah Jane Smith
Tegan you had characters like that but
you also had characters like Nyssa
Romana Victoria Zoe characters from the
past characters from the Future
characters from other planets characters
that weren't even human
and the other reason I don't want the
new companion to be from modern day
earth is I'm really kind of done with a
doctor on modern earth and having that
be his default I want him out in space
adventuring flying amongst the stars
with the sky's the limit
I don't want to add to have him keep
coming back to earth every couple of
episodes because that's where his
companion lives or they've got family
that's still there or whatever else I
would really like the entirety of series
10 to be set anywhere that's not earth I
don't want it to go to earth for that
entire series that would make me very
happy again I'm not saying
come back to earth I'm not saying the
earth stories are lousy for some reason
but I'm just tired of it
give me the variety the sky's the limit
we could have companions from anywhere
in the entire scope of space and time
why are we still getting these young
women from Earth modern day enough so
that's me what about you
do you like this template do you like
that the companions check all three of
these boxes for the most part am I
completely nuts or do you want something
even more outlandish than what I've said
what would your ideal next companion be
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned